[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en 2010 elle juste après son élection
emmanuel macron fait un discours devant
la pyramide du louvre la pyramide c'est
un symbole cacher non
[Musique]
bonjour thomas bonjour julien tu parles
d'un signe cacher pour les francs maçons
ou pour les illuminati écoute le louvre
c'est un monument très important de
paris ça a été le lieu du pouvoir royal
pendant des siècles en france et c'est
aussi aujourd'hui le musée le plus
visité au monde ça fait plusieurs
raisons pour qu'un président français
nouvellement élu se rendre dans un tel
lieu chargé d'histoire et de symboles
quant à y voir un signe d'allégeance aux
illuminati mais ça existe les illuminati
ça a existé entre 1776 et 1785 sur cette
période on a des preuves de leur
existence mais depuis ça existe surtout
dans les livres et sur youtube mais pas
dans la réalité après à supposer qu'il y
ait des gens qui dirigent le monde en
secret je vois pas bien la logique qui
aurait à ce qu'il sème des indices comme
ça un peu partout sur des bouteilles de
soda sur des paquets de cigarettes des
tee-shirts ou à l'occasion des victoires
électorales pourtant je ne suis pas le
seul à m'être fait la réflexion faire un
discours avec un grand triangle arrière
plan c'est évident de ça l'excité les
complotistes c'est évident pour toi
parce que tu es familier de la culture
internet et donc de toutes les
obsessions complotistes mais rien de
permet de dire déjà que c'est le cas d'
emmanuel macron toi tu vois un triangle
une pyramide et tu pense immédiatement à
une symbolique très présente dans
l'imaginaire du complot mais la plupart
des gens bah il voit juste qu'on est au
louvre en gros qu'on veut voir des
signes on envoie en psychiatrie on
appelle ça la peau fini c'est cette
tendance à repérer des relations et donc
un sens caché à des éléments épars qui a
priori n'ont pas de lien entre eux il ya
des coïncidences étranges quand même sur
les réseaux on observe la formation de
communauté de détective digitaux ils
cherchent des signes partout uniquement
guidés par leur intuition ou par leurs
obsessions fausse coïncidence ou vrai
complot les théories du complot invente
souvent des coïncidences imaginaire ou
fantaisistes il fabrique de fausses
preuves et ses fausses preuves eh bien
elles se répandent parce que la plupart
des gens ne prennent pas le temps de les
vérifier un exemple sur les réseaux
sociaux la majorité des contenus qui
renvoie vers une page extérieurs sont
partagés sans que la page en question
soient préalablement consulté par les
utilisateurs qui vous la partage ok mais
les théories du complot s'appuie aussi
sur des coïncidences avérée on est
d'accord oui c'est vrai le problème
c'est qu'elles prétendent que ces
coïncidences ont une explication cacher
alors qu'en réalité elles sont dues au
hasard comme quoi par exemple comme le
fait qu'on peut trouver tout un tas de
coïncidences troublantes entre les
destins d'abraham lincoln et de john
fitzgerald kennedy qui sont deux
présidents américains morts assassinés
mais on peut aussi en trouver concernant
deux autres président assassiné et on
pourrait multiplier ainsi les exemples
si l'on prenait juste le temps de le
faire tout simplement parce que le
hasard produit naturellement des
coïncidences sens qu'elle est pourtant
la moindre signification
[Musique]